hi everyone sal khan here from khan
academy my social security number is
eight five seven
three two five five six seven
no it's not i wouldn't wouldn't tell you
my social security number like that and
that's because it is personally
identifiable information or pii
and there's a reason why you want to
keep that to yourself or at least limit
who has access to pii
because if someone has access they can
expose your privacy tell the world where
you live they could track you and they
could tell the world what you've been up
to maybe when you should be working what
websites you're visiting or even worse
potentially they could steal your
identity take money out of your bank
account take a credit card in your name
do some other form of identity theft
that could be embarrassing or super
costly
so if you have some type of a service
either online or otherwise that's asking
for something like your social security
number or
your birthday which might be a little
bit more indirect or your email address
or your phone number
you might ask why sometimes there's a
legitimate reason why they need to know
these things but many times i'd argue
even most of the time there might not be
a legitimate reason and so you need to
ask yourself well what are they going to
do with it and if you don't feel
comfortable giving that information ask
yourself do you really need that service
so think seriously about your pii
unfortunately bad actors on the internet
are coming up with new ways of
leveraging both direct pii personally
identifiable information like social
security numbers even biometrics even
your name and indirect measures like
your or indirect pieces of pii like your
birthday or your address or your email
address or your phone number that can be
put together to do shady things with
your identity so be very careful